- ยินดีต้อนรับกลับมาสู่ Understanding Quantum
Information and Computation
ผมชื่อ John Watrous และ
ผมเป็นผู้อำนวยการฝ่ายเทคนิคของ IBM Quantum Education
นี่คือบทเรียนที่หกของซีรีส์นี้ และเป็นบทเรียนที่สองใน
หน่วยที่สองของซีรีส์ ซึ่งเกี่ยวกับอัลกอริทึมควอนตัม
ในบทเรียนที่แล้ว เราได้พูดถึงโมเดลการคำนวณแบบ
query และเราเห็นว่าในโมเดลนั้น อัลกอริทึมควอนตัมสามารถ
ให้ข้อได้เปรียบที่โดดเด่น
เหนือกว่าอัลกอริทึมแบบคลาสสิก รวมถึงข้อได้เปรียบแบบเอ็กซ์โพเนนเชียลในกรณีของปัญหาของ Simon
น่าเสียดายที่โมเดล
query ไม่ได้มีความเกี่ยวข้อง
ในทางปฏิบัติโดยตรงหรือทันที
แนวคิดของกล่องดำเป็นสิ่งที่เป็นนามธรรม
ที่มีประโยชน์มาก แต่เราต้องทำงานอีก
สักหน่อยถ้าเราจะนำ
ข้อมูลเชิงลึกที่เราได้
จากโมเดล query ไปใช้ในบริบทการคำนวณมาตรฐานที่อินพุตถูกให้เป็นสตริงของบิต
แทนที่จะเป็นออราเคิลหรือกล่องดำ
จุดประสงค์หลักของบทเรียนนี้คือการสร้างพื้นฐาน
ที่เราสามารถทำแบบนั้นได้
นี่คือภาพรวมของบทเรียน เนื้อหาส่วนใหญ่ของบทเรียนนี้ เราจะโฟกัส
ที่ต้นทุนการคำนวณ
หรือพูดอีกอย่างคือ งานคำนวณแต่ละอย่าง
ยากแค่ไหน และเราจะวัดความยากนั้นได้ยังไง
พูดคร่าวๆ มันแปลว่าเราต้องรอ
การคำนวณให้เสร็จนานแค่ไหน และท้ายที่สุดแล้ว ปัญหา
การคำนวณไหน
ที่เราแก้ได้ และ
อันไหนที่เกินความสามารถของเรา
เราจะเริ่มด้วย
ตัวอย่างสองสามอัน การแยกตัวประกอบจำนวนเต็มและการคำนวณตัวหาร
ร่วมมากหรือ GCD
พวกนี้เป็นตัวอย่างที่ดีมากสำหรับอธิบาย
หลักการพื้นฐาน และทั้งสองอย่างก็
เกี่ยวข้องกับอัลกอริทึมของ Shor อย่างมาก ซึ่งเราจะ
พูดถึงในบทเรียนถัดไป
ดังนั้นเราจะได้
ประโยชน์สองเท่าจากตัวอย่างพวกนี้
จากนั้นเราจะพูดถึงแนวคิดของต้นทุนการคำนวณโดยทั่วไป และวิธีวัดมัน
มีหลายวิธี
ที่ทำได้ แต่เราจะโฟกัสค่อนข้าง
แคบว่าเราจะทำแบบนี้ด้วยโมเดล circuit ของการคำนวณได้ยังไง
โดยเฉพาะ Boolean circuit
และ quantum circuit
โฟกัสตรงนี้จะอยู่ที่อัลกอริทึม ไม่ใช่ฮาร์ดแวร์
คอมพิวเตอร์ และเราจะสนใจ
ว่าต้นทุนของการรัน
อัลกอริทึมเพิ่มขึ้นยังไงเมื่อปัญหาที่มันถูกรันมีขนาดใหญ่ขึ้น มากกว่า
จะสนใจว่ากี่วินาที
กี่นาที หรือกี่ชั่วโมง
ที่การคำนวณบางอย่างต้องใช้
แนวคิดที่เป็นแรงจูงใจของมุมมองนี้คือ อัลกอริทึมมี
ความสำคัญพื้นฐาน
จนถึงทุกวันนี้ เรา
ยังคงรันอัลกอริทึมที่ถูกพัฒนา
เมื่อนานมาแล้ว และโดยธรรมชาติแล้ว มันจะถูกนำไปใช้
กับปัญหาที่
ใหญ่ขึ้นเรื่อยๆ โดยใช้ฮาร์ดแวร์ที่เร็วกว่าและเชื่อถือได้มากกว่าเมื่อเทคโนโลยีพัฒนาขึ้น
และวิธีที่มันขยายขนาดบอกเราได้มาก
เกี่ยวกับว่ามันมีประโยชน์แค่ไหน และจะยังคงมีประโยชน์ต่อไปแค่ไหน
ในส่วนสุดท้ายของบทเรียน เราจะหันมาดูงานที่สำคัญมาก ซึ่งคือการรันการคำนวณแบบคลาสสิก
บนคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัม เหตุผลที่มันสำคัญไม่ใช่เพราะเราหวังจะแทนที่คอมพิวเตอร์คลาสสิก
ด้วยคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัม
ซึ่งดูไม่น่าจะเกิดขึ้นเร็วๆ นี้ ถ้ามันจะเกิดขึ้นเลย แต่เพราะมันเปิดโอกาส
ความเป็นไปได้ที่น่าสนใจมากมาย
สำหรับอัลกอริทึมควอนตัม
โดยเฉพาะ เมื่อเรารู้วิธีรันการคำนวณแบบคลาสสิก
บนคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัม มันจะพร้อมใช้งานสำหรับอัลกอริทึม
ควอนตัมในฐานะซับรูทีน
ดังนั้นเราสามารถ
ใช้ประโยชน์จากทุกอย่างที่เรารู้เกี่ยวกับอัลกอริทึมคลาสสิกในการแสวงหาข้อได้เปรียบทางการคำนวณควอนตัม
คอมพิวเตอร์คลาสสิกที่เรามีในปัจจุบันเป็นสิ่งมหัศจรรย์ทางเทคโนโลยีอย่างแท้จริง
มันเร็วอย่างเหลือเชื่อ แต่ก็ไม่ได้เร็วจนไม่มีปัญหาการคำนวณ
ใดที่เกินความสามารถ
ปัญหาการคำนวณบางอย่าง
ยากโดยเนื้อแท้จนแม้ว่าเราจะมี
อัลกอริทึมในการแก้มัน ไม่มีคอมพิวเตอร์บนโลกนี้ในปัจจุบัน
ที่เร็วพอจะรัน
อัลกอริทึมเหล่านี้จนเสร็จบนอินพุตที่มีขนาดปานกลาง ภายในช่วงชีวิตของมนุษย์
หรือแม้แต่ภายในช่วงอายุ
ของโลกเองเลย
เพื่ออธิบายเพิ่มเติม มาดู
ปัญหาการแยกตัวประกอบจำนวนเต็มกัน
โจทย์ปัญหาง่ายมาก อินพุตของปัญหาคือจำนวนเต็ม N ที่มีค่าอย่างน้อยสอง และเอาต์พุตคือ
การแยกตัวประกอบเฉพาะของ N
ซึ่งหมายความว่าเป็นรายการของตัวประกอบจำนวนเฉพาะของ N พร้อมกับกำลังที่จำนวนเฉพาะเหล่านี้ต้องถูกยก
เพื่อจะได้ N โดย
การคูณมันทั้งหมดเข้าด้วยกัน
แน่นอนว่าเราสามารถคูณตัวประกอบเฉพาะเข้าด้วยกันในลำดับใดก็ได้ แต่นอกเหนือจากลำดับแล้ว
การแยกตัวประกอบเฉพาะจะมีค่าเดียวเสมอสำหรับทุกค่า N
ข้อเท็จจริงนั้นเรียกว่า
ทฤษฎีบทมูลฐานของเลขคณิต และถ้าสนใจ
อยากเรียนรู้เพิ่มเติม มันเป็นสิ่งที่หาได้
ที่ตอนต้นของ
หนังสือทฤษฎีจำนวนหลายเล่ม
เป็นตัวอย่างง่ายๆ นี่คือการแยกตัวประกอบเฉพาะ
ของเลข 12
มันคือสองยกกำลังสอง
คูณสามยกกำลังหนึ่ง
ไม่น่าแปลกใจที่
คอมพิวเตอร์สามารถบอกคุณได้ในพริบตา โดยการค้นหา
ตัวประกอบเฉพาะแบบวนซ้ำ
นี่อีกตัวอย่างหนึ่ง ผมจะไม่พยายามอ่านเลขนี้
มันประมาณ 3.4 ควอตทูออร์เดซิลเลียน และต้องยอมรับว่าผมรู้สึกแปลกที่มีชื่อเรียกแบบนี้ด้วย
แต่ยังไงก็ตาม มันมี 46 หลักทศนิยม และตรงนี้จะเห็น
การแยกตัวประกอบเฉพาะของมัน
คอมพิวเตอร์ก็บอกได้เหมือนกัน ผมแยกตัวประกอบเลขนี้โดยใช้วิธีการแยกตัวประกอบที่รวมอยู่ในไลบรารีคณิตศาสตร์เชิงสัญลักษณ์
สำหรับ Python
และใช้เวลาไม่กี่วินาที ซึ่งไม่ได้นานเป็นพิเศษ แต่มีการหน่วงที่สังเกตได้
และแน่นอนว่าเมธอด factor N ไม่ได้หาการแยกตัวประกอบเฉพาะนี้โดยค้นหาตัวประกอบเฉพาะแบบไร้เดียงสา
จริงๆ แล้วมันใช้อัลกอริทึม
หลายอันผสมกัน รวมถึงอันที่เรียกว่า
อัลกอริทึม colored row ซึ่งเป็นอัลกอริทึมสำหรับแยกตัวประกอบ
ที่ซับซ้อนกว่าการค้นหาตัวประกอบเฉพาะแบบวนซ้ำ
ไร้เดียงสา และถึงแม้มันอาจดู
เหมือนเลขที่ใหญ่มาก
ในฐานะอินพุตของปัญหาการคำนวณ มันไม่ได้ใหญ่มากเลยจริงๆ
มันมีแค่ 46 ตัวอักษร
นี่อีกตัวอย่าง เป็นเลขที่มี 309 หลักทศนิยม
ถ้าเราเขียนในรูปเลขฐานสอง มันมี 1,024 บิต และนั่นคือ
เหตุผลที่มันเรียกว่า RSA1024
การแยกตัวประกอบเฉพาะของเลขนี้ยังไม่เป็นที่ทราบในปัจจุบัน
เลขนี้มาจาก
RSA factoring challenge ซึ่งจัดโดย RSA
Laboratories ตั้งแต่ปี 1991 ถึง 2007
พวกเขาเสนอรางวัลเงินสด
สำหรับการแยกตัวประกอบเฉพาะของเลขหลายตัวที่มีขนาด
ใหญ่ขึ้นเรื่อยๆ รวมถึงเลขนี้ ซึ่งมีมูลค่า $100,000 US
แต่รางวัลนั้นไม่เคยถูกเก็บไป
ความปลอดภัยของระบบเข้ารหัส
กุญแจสาธารณะ RSA อาศัยความยาก
ของการแยกตัวประกอบจำนวนเต็ม
ถ้าคุณแยกตัวประกอบได้ คุณ
ก็ทำลายระบบได้ ดังนั้นจุดประสงค์ของความท้าทายนี้โดยพื้นฐานแล้วคือติดตาม
สถานะของศิลปะในการแยกตัวประกอบ
สรุปคือ
การแยกตัวประกอบเลขนี้เกินความสามารถปัจจุบันของเรา
เท่าที่เรารู้
ปัญหานี้ซับซ้อนเกินไปสำหรับคอมพิวเตอร์คลาสสิก
ที่จะแก้ในทางปฏิบัติ
เลข RSA challenge ที่ใหญ่ที่สุดที่ถูกแยกตัวประกอบได้จนถึงตอนนี้ มี 250 หลักทศนิยม
อาจจะอ่านบนหน้าจอ
ยากสักหน่อย แต่นี่คือการแยก
ตัวประกอบเฉพาะของ RSA250
ทำได้ในปี 2020 โดยใช้อัลกอริทึมที่เรียกว่า number field sieve และเป็นความพยายามร่วมกันของคอมพิวเตอร์
หลายหมื่นเครื่องทั่วโลก
ทีนี้ มาดูปัญหา
การคำนวณอีกอันหนึ่ง ซึ่งคือปัญหาการคำนวณตัวหาร
ร่วมมาก หรือ GCD
ของจำนวนเต็มไม่เป็นลบสองจำนวน
นี่คือโจทย์ของปัญหา อินพุตประกอบด้วยเลข
สองตัวคราวนี้ คือ N และ M
และเราจะสมมติว่า
ทั้งสองไม่ได้เท่ากับศูนย์ทั้งคู่
เป้าหมายคือการคำนวณ
GCD ของเลขสองตัวนี้ ซึ่งคือจำนวนเต็ม D ที่ใหญ่ที่สุดที่หาร N และ M ลงตัวทั้งคู่
และถ้าคุณลองคิดถึง
การแยกตัวประกอบเฉพาะของ N และ M จะพบว่า GCD คือผลคูณของจำนวนเฉพาะทั้งหมด
ที่หาร N และ M ลงตัวทั้งคู่ ยกกำลังด้วยค่าน้อยสุดของกำลังที่ปรากฏในการ
แยกตัวประกอบเฉพาะทั้งสอง
มันเกี่ยวข้องกับปัญหา
การแยกตัวประกอบจำนวนเต็ม แต่กลับง่ายกว่ามากๆ
สำหรับคอมพิวเตอร์ เราสามารถคำนวณ GCD สำหรับเลขที่มีหลายพันหลัก
ได้ในพริบตา
มันไม่มีประโยชน์เท่าไหร่ที่ผมจะพยายามแสดงตัวอย่างบนหน้าจอ เพราะเราอาจเติม
หน้าจอทั้งหมดด้วยตัวเลข และก็ยังจะอธิบาย
ปัญหาที่แก้ได้ง่ายๆ ของปัญหานี้อยู่
แต่ถ้าสนใจ ลองกดลิงก์ในคำอธิบายวิดีโอไปที่หน้าตำราเรียนของบทเรียนนี้ จะเจอโค้ดเซลล์
สำหรับการคำนวณแบบที่
ผมพูดถึง รวมถึงอันที่คำนวณ
GCD ของเลขใหญ่ๆ และคุณลองเล่นเองได้
คำถามคือ ทำไมถึงเป็นไปได้ที่จะคำนวณ GCD ได้ง่ายขนาดนี้?
และคำตอบคือ เรามีอัลกอริทึมที่มีประสิทธิภาพ
ในการคำนวณ GCD
หนึ่งในนั้นคืออัลกอริทึมของ Euclid ซึ่งถูกค้นพบเมื่อกว่า 2,000 ปีที่แล้ว แต่ก็ยังมี
อัลกอริทึม GCD ที่มีประสิทธิภาพอื่นๆ อีก
และแน่นอนว่าเรากำลังพูดถึงอัลกอริทึมคลาสสิกตรงนี้ ซึ่งนำไปสู่คำถามอีกข้อ
มันเป็นไปได้ไหมที่จะมี
อัลกอริทึมคลาสสิกที่มีประสิทธิภาพสำหรับการแยกตัวประกอบจำนวนเต็ม
ที่จะทำให้เราแยกตัวประกอบเลขอย่าง RSA1024
ได้ในพริบตา?
และคำตอบคือได้ เป็นไปได้อย่างแน่นอนที่จะมีอัลกอริทึมคลาสสิก
ที่มีประสิทธิภาพสำหรับการแยกตัวประกอบ และปัจจุบันเราไม่รู้วิธี
ที่จะตัดความเป็นไปได้นั้นออก สิ่งที่เราพูดได้คือ
เรายังไม่เจอมันเลย
สำหรับอัลกอริทึมแยกตัวประกอบ
แบบคลาสสิกทั้งหมดที่เรารู้จัก เรายังคง
ค้นหาตัวประกอบเป็นหลัก
และนั่นทำให้เลขอย่าง
RSA1024 เกินความสามารถของเรา
อัลกอริทึม GCD ที่มีประสิทธิภาพ
ในทางกลับกัน ไม่ได้ทำงานแบบนั้น
มันไม่ได้ค้นหา
ตัวหารร่วมมาก มันแค่สร้าง
มันขึ้นมาด้วยกระบวนการกลไกที่มีต้นทุนใกล้เคียง
กับการคูณเลข
สองตัวเดียวกัน และผมจะพูดเพิ่มเติมอีกนิดเรื่องนี้ทีหลังในบทเรียน
แน่นอน ทั้งหมดนี้กำลังนำไป
สู่อัลกอริทึมของ Shor ซึ่งเราจะเห็นในบทเรียนถัดไป ซึ่งเป็นอัลกอริทึมควอนตัมที่มีประสิทธิภาพ
สำหรับการคำนวณการแยกตัวประกอบเฉพาะ แต่เรายังมีเนื้อหา
ที่ต้องครอบคลุมอีกก่อนจะถึงตรงนั้น
ต่อไปเราจะพูด
เกี่ยวกับกรอบทางคณิตศาสตร์ที่เราสามารถวัดต้นทุนการคำนวณ
ของอัลกอริทึมต่างๆ
รวมถึงอันที่เราพูดถึงไปแล้ว
พูดให้ชัด เราจะโฟกัสแคบๆ เฉพาะ circuit ซึ่งเป็นแค่ส่วนเล็กๆ
ของหัวข้อที่กว้างกว่ามาก
มาเริ่มด้วยมุมมองระดับสูงของการคำนวณทั่วไป
จากบทเรียนที่แล้ว หมายความว่าโดยเฉพาะเราไม่ได้คิด
เรื่องปัญหาแบบ query
เราคิดเรื่อง
ปัญหาที่อินพุตถูกให้มาอย่างชัดเจนเป็นสตริงเลขฐานสอง
อย่างที่ผมพูดในบทเรียนที่แล้ว เราสามารถใช้
สัญลักษณ์อื่นได้ถ้าเลือก แต่มาทำให้มันง่ายและใช้สตริงเลขฐานสอง
สำหรับทั้งอินพุตและเอาต์พุต
การคำนวณนั้นสามารถถูกจำลองหรืออธิบายได้หลายวิธี เช่น ด้วยโมเดลเครื่อง Turing
ของการคำนวณ
Boolean circuit, quantum circuit หรือโปรแกรมที่เขียนใน
ภาษาอย่าง Python หรือภาษาอื่นตามที่ชอบ
อย่างที่ผมพูดเมื่อกี้ เราจะโฟกัสที่
circuit ทั้ง Boolean และควอนตัม
ก่อนอื่น มาใช้เวลาอีกสักหน่อยพูดถึงอินพุตและเอาต์พุต ซึ่งเราสมมติว่าเป็นสตริงเลขฐานสอง
โดยใช้สตริงเลขฐานสอง เราสามารถเข้ารหัสอ็อบเจกต์
ทางคณิตศาสตร์หลายประเภท เช่น ตัวเลข เวกเตอร์
เมทริกซ์ กราฟ
คำอธิบายของโมเลกุล เป็นต้น รวมถึงรายการของอ็อบเจกต์เหล่านี้และอื่นๆ อีกด้วย
เป็นตัวอย่างง่ายๆ ถ้าเราอยากเข้ารหัสจำนวนเต็ม
ไม่เป็นลบเป็นสตริงเลขฐานสอง เราใช้เลขฐานสองได้
ในตารางนี้ จะเห็นจำนวนเต็มไม่เป็นลบ 13
ตัวแรกพร้อมกับการแสดงผลหรือ
การเข้ารหัสแบบเลขฐานสอง
ในคอลัมน์ที่สามนี้ จะเห็นความยาวของ
การเข้ารหัสแต่ละตัว ซึ่งก็คือจำนวนบิตทั้งหมดที่ต้องใช้สำหรับการเข้ารหัส
และนี่คือสูตรง่ายๆ ที่บอกว่าต้องใช้กี่บิต
โดยทั่วไปสำหรับจำนวนเต็มไม่เป็นลบ N ใดๆ
สังเกตโดยเฉพาะว่า
ความยาวของการเข้ารหัสโดยทั่วไปจะเล็กกว่า
ตัวเลขนั้นเองมาก
มันเป็นแบบลอการิทึมของตัวเลข
RSA1024 เป็นตัวอย่าง มีการเข้ารหัสที่ยาว 1,024 แต่ตัวเลขนั้นเอง
แน่นอนว่าใหญ่กว่านั้นมาก
วิธีเข้ารหัสนี้ใช้ได้
สำหรับจำนวนเต็มไม่เป็นลบ แต่ถ้าเราต้องการจัดการ
จำนวนเต็มใดๆ รวมถึงจำนวนลบ เรา
แค่เพิ่มบิตเครื่องหมายเข้าไป
เราสามารถให้มีเลขศูนย์นำหน้าได้กี่ตัวก็ได้ในการเข้ารหัสเหล่านี้ ถ้าเราต้องการให้การเข้ารหัส
เติมเต็มบล็อกของบิตหรือรีจิสเตอร์ที่มีขนาดคงที่
ตราบใดที่มันใหญ่พอ บางทีก็สะดวกมาก
นี่ไม่ใช่วิธีเดียวที่จะเข้ารหัสจำนวนเต็มเป็นสตริงของบิต
มีวิธีอื่นๆ ที่ทำได้ แต่นี่เป็น
วิธีมาตรฐานทั่วไป
สำหรับอ็อบเจกต์ประเภทอื่นที่อาจเป็นอินพุตหรือเอาต์พุตของปัญหา
การคำนวณที่เราสนใจ เราสามารถคิด
วิธีเข้ารหัสอื่นๆ ได้
ตัวอย่างเช่น ลองคิดว่า
จะเข้ารหัสเวกเตอร์หรือกราฟเป็นสตริงเลขฐานสองยังไง หรือลองคิดว่าจะเข้ารหัส
สตริงเลขฐานสองสองอัน
เป็นสตริงเลขฐานสองอันเดียว โดยใช้แค่สัญลักษณ์ศูนย์และหนึ่ง โดยไม่มีช่องว่างหรือสัญลักษณ์อื่น
เพื่อแยกสตริงทั้งสอง มีวิธีที่จะ
ทำสิ่งเหล่านี้แน่นอน และจริงๆ แล้ว เรามีอิสระมาก
ในการเลือกว่าจะทำยังไง
บ่อยครั้งจะไม่มีมาตรฐานเดียวหรือวิธีที่ตกลงกันเป็นสากลในการเข้ารหัสสิ่งที่เรากำลังพูดถึง
เป็นสตริงเลขฐานสอง
แต่ก็ไม่เป็นไร เราแค่เลือกอันหนึ่ง หรือจะคิดอันใหม่ก็ได้ถ้าชอบ
จากมุมมองเชิงรูปธรรม เราคิดเรื่องการคำนวณว่าเป็นการแปลงเชิงกลไกบนสตริงของบิต
และรายละเอียดของวิธี
เข้ารหัสที่เราใช้ก็สำคัญในระดับหนึ่ง
แต่ถึงอย่างนั้น เมื่อเราออกแบบและ
วิเคราะห์อัลกอริทึม เรามักจะไม่ค่อยกังวลเรื่องรายละเอียดของ
วิธีเข้ารหัสมากนัก
ถ้าคุณขอให้คนสองคนคิดวิธีเข้ารหัส เช่น โมเลกุลประเภทหนึ่ง
เป็นสตริงเลขฐานสอง
คุณอาจคาดว่าพวกเขาจะคิดวิธีที่ต่างกัน แต่ถ้าเป็นคนที่มีเหตุผลและรู้ว่าทำอะไรอยู่
คุณก็คาดได้อย่างสมเหตุสมผลว่ามันจะเป็นกระบวนการ
คำนวณที่ค่อนข้างง่ายในการแปลงไปมาระหว่างสองวิธีเข้ารหัส
ซึ่งน่าจะเป็นการคำนวณ
ที่ตรงไปตรงมามากและค่อนข้างง่ายเมื่อเทียบกับการคำนวณจริง
ที่เราสนใจ
สรุปคือ รายละเอียดเกี่ยวกับวิธีเข้ารหัสที่เราใช้มักจะเป็นเรื่องรองและโฟกัสของเราอยู่ที่
อัลกอริทึมนั้นเอง
เรื่องพวกนี้จะไม่เป็นปัญหาสำหรับบทเรียนนี้ เราจะโฟกัสหลักๆ ที่ปัญหาเกี่ยวกับจำนวนเต็ม ซึ่งเราจะสมมติว่าเข้ารหัสแบบเลขฐานสอง
แต่เป็นเรื่องที่ควรรู้ไว้
โดยทั่วไป สำหรับปัญหาประเภทใดก็ตามที่เรากำลังพูดถึง ความยาวอินพุตหมายถึง
จำนวนบิตที่ต้องใช้เพื่อเข้ารหัสอินพุต
และเรามองว่าความยาวอินพุตเป็นขนาดของอินสแตนซ์ของปัญหาที่เรากำลังคิดอยู่
ทีนี้ มาดู
การคำนวณเอง ซึ่งแสดงด้วย
สี่เหลี่ยมสีน้ำเงินในรูปนี้
วิธีที่เราจะวัด
ต้นทุนของการคำนวณนี้คือนับจำนวนการดำเนินการพื้นฐานที่มันต้องใช้
พูดง่ายๆ การดำเนินการพื้นฐานคือการดำเนินการที่เกี่ยวข้องกับจำนวนบิตหรือ qubit
ที่คงที่จำนวนน้อย
ที่สามารถทำได้อย่างรวดเร็วและง่ายดาย เช่น การคำนวณ AND ของ
สองบิต เป็นต้น
ในระดับทางการ
มีหลายวิธีที่จะนิยามว่าการดำเนินการพื้นฐานคืออะไร ขึ้นอยู่กับว่าเราใช้
โมเดลการคำนวณแบบไหน
ตัวอย่างเช่น การดำเนินการพื้นฐานอาจเป็นหนึ่งขั้นตอนของเครื่อง Turing ถ้าเราใช้โมเดลนั้น
สำหรับบทเรียนนี้ เราจะโฟกัสที่โมเดล circuit อย่างที่ผมบอกไปแล้ว และโดยเฉพาะ quantum
และ Boolean circuit
เมื่อเราทำงานกับ circuit มันเป็นเรื่องปกติที่เราจะคิดว่าแต่ละ gate เป็นตัวแทนของการดำเนินการพื้นฐาน
เราเห็น quantum gate หลายตัวมาแล้วในซีรีส์นี้
รวมถึง X, Y และ Z gate, Hadamard gate, S และ T gate
controlled NOT gate, swap gate, Toffoli gate และ Fredkin gate
เราได้พูดถึง query gate ในบริบทของโมเดล query ด้วย แต่เราจะไม่ทำงานภายในโมเดล query ในบทเรียนนี้ ดังนั้นเราจะไม่กังวลเรื่อง
query gate ตอนนี้
เรายังเห็นว่าการดำเนินการยูนิทารีใดๆ บนจำนวน qubit ใดๆ
สามารถถูกมองเป็น gate ได้ถ้าเราต้องการ
แต่สำหรับการวัดต้นทุน มันไม่ได้ช่วยอะไรเท่าไหร่ ดังนั้นสิ่งที่เราจะทำคือเราจะเลือก
ชุด gate
และเราจะมองว่าชุดนั้นเป็นชุดการดำเนินการพื้นฐานของเรา
อันดับแรก เราจะรวม
gate ยูนิทารีแบบ qubit เดียวที่เห็นตรงนี้
คือ X, Y และ Z gate
Hadamard gate และ S และ T gate รวมถึงอินเวิร์ส
หรือคอนจูเกตทรานสโพสของมัน
จริงๆ เราไม่จำเป็นต้องใช้ gate ทั้งหมดนี้ เมื่อเรามี Hadamard และ T gate เราก็สร้างที่เหลือได้
แต่เพื่อความสะดวก เราจะรวมทั้งหมดเข้าไป
เราจะรวม controlled NOT gate ด้วย และพวกนี้จะเป็น
gate หลาย qubit ตัวเดียวในชุดของเรา
และสุดท้ายเราจะรวมการวัดฐานมาตรฐานแบบ qubit เดียว เพื่อที่เราจะได้ข้อมูลคลาสสิก
ออกมาจาก circuit ของเรา
ถ้าเราโฟกัสแค่ gate ยูนิทารีแล้วลืม
การวัดสักครู่ เราจะได้สิ่งที่เรียกว่า
universal gate set
สิ่งที่มันหมายความคือ
การดำเนินการยูนิทารีใดๆ บนจำนวน qubit ใดๆ สามารถ
ถูกสร้างขึ้นอย่างตรงเป๊ะ
หรือใกล้เคียงได้ตามต้องการ
ด้วย quantum circuit ที่สร้างจากแค่ gate เหล่านี้
พูดอีกอย่างคือ นี่คือ
ชุด gate ที่ดีพอที่เราสามารถสร้างการดำเนินการ
ยูนิทารีใดๆ ออกมาจากมัน
ไม่จำเป็นต้องตรงเป๊ะเสมอไป แต่เราจะประมาณ
ให้ดีเท่าที่ต้องการได้
มันอาจต้องใช้ gate เยอะ และจริงๆ แล้วก็ไม่ยากที่จะเห็นว่ามันต้องใช้
gate เยอะบางครั้ง
แต่ถึงอย่างนั้น มันเป็นไปได้เสมอ
การพิสูจน์ว่านี่คือ universal gate set ไม่ใช่เรื่องง่ายนะ และเราจะไม่พูดถึงว่า
ทำยังไงในซีรีส์นี้
แต่มันเป็นข้อเท็จจริงที่รู้กันดี และจริงๆ แล้วมี
วิธีพิสูจน์ได้หลายวิธี
ก็มีชุด gate อื่นๆ ที่บางทีใช้
แทนชุดนี้ เช่น Toffoli gate, Hadamard gate และ S gate นอกเหนือจากการวัด
แต่นี่เป็นตัวเลือกมาตรฐานทั่วไป
สรุปแล้ว พวกนี้คือ
การดำเนินการควอนตัมที่เราจะมองว่าเป็นพื้นฐาน
สำหรับ Boolean circuit
เราจะถือว่า gate สี่ตัวนี้เป็น
การดำเนินการพื้นฐาน: AND gate, OR gate, NOT gate และ FANOUT
FANOUT นะ ไม่ได้
ถูกนับเป็น gate เสมอไป แต่มันจะ
สำคัญที่เราต้องทำแบบนี้อย่างที่เราจะเห็นทีหลังในบทเรียน
คล้ายกับที่เรามี
สำหรับชุด quantum gate มาตรฐาน ชุดนี้ก็ซ้ำซ้อนเล็กน้อย
ไม่จำเป็นต้องมีทั้ง AND และ OR คุณสามารถสร้างอันหนึ่งจากอีกอันด้วย NOT gate สามตัว
แต่การรวมทั้งสองไม่เสียหาย และก็สะดวกดี
คุณอาจรู้อยู่แล้วว่านี่คือ universal gate set
สำหรับการคำนวณแบบกำหนดได้ หมายความว่าฟังก์ชันใดๆ
จากบิตไปเป็นบิต
สามารถสร้างด้วย Boolean circuit ที่ประกอบจาก gate ในชุดนี้
อีกครั้ง เหมือนที่เรา
มีสำหรับ quantum circuit นี่ไม่ได้หมายความว่าทุกฟังก์ชันจะสร้างได้อย่างมีประสิทธิภาพ
ด้วย Boolean circuit
และจริงๆ แล้ว ฟังก์ชันส่วนใหญ่
สามารถสร้างได้ด้วย circuit ที่ใหญ่มากเท่านั้น
เพราะเหตุผลง่ายๆ ว่ามีฟังก์ชันเยอะมาก
และไม่สามารถมี circuit เล็กๆ ให้ทุกตัวได้ circuit เล็กๆ
ไม่พอแจก
ความเป็น universality พิสูจน์ได้
ง่ายกว่าในกรณีนี้เมื่อเทียบกับกรณีควอนตัม
ถ้าคุณยังไม่
รู้วิธีพิสูจน์มัน ลองคิดดู
แล้วลองหาคำตอบถ้าสนใจ
ตอนนี้เราตัดสินใจแล้วว่า
gate ไหนที่เราจะอนุญาตและเราจะถือว่า
เป็นการดำเนินการพื้นฐาน เราสามารถคิดได้ว่าต้องใช้เท่าไหร่
เพื่อทำ
การคำนวณต่างๆ
เพื่อทำแบบนั้น เราจะ
ใช้นิยามของขนาดของ circuit นี้
นิยามนี้ใช้ได้กับทั้ง
Boolean และ quantum circuit และมันง่ายมาก
ขนาดของ circuit คือ
จำนวน gate ทั้งหมดที่มันมี
ตัวอย่างเช่น ถ้าเรากลับไป
ที่ตัวอย่างเดิมที่เราเห็นหลายครั้ง ซึ่งคือ Boolean circuit สำหรับคำนวณ exclusive OR ของสองบิต
เราจะเห็นว่ามันมีขนาดเจ็ด
เพราะมี gate เจ็ดตัว FANOUT gate สองตัว NOT gate สองตัว
AND gate สองตัว และ OR gate หนึ่งตัว ถ้าเราตัดสินใจ
ไม่นับ FANOUT gate ซึ่งเป็นเรื่องปกติ มันจะมีขนาดเท่ากับห้า
แต่เราจะนับ FANOUT gate ดังนั้นขนาดของมันคือเจ็ด
ขนาดของ circuit
สอดคล้องกับจำนวนการดำเนินการพื้นฐาน
ที่เราต้องทำ
ถ้าเราทำ
การดำเนินการเหล่านั้นทีละอันและขนาดจะบอก
เราว่ามันใช้เวลานานแค่ไหน
ดังนั้นคุณสามารถคิดว่าขนาด circuit แสดงถึงเวลาทำงานแบบลำดับ
นี่จะเป็นวิธีที่เรา
วัดต้นทุนการคำนวณสำหรับบทเรียนนี้
มีคุณสมบัติอีกอย่าง
ของ circuit ที่สามารถถูกมองเป็นเวลา
ที่ต้องใช้ในการรัน circuit และนั่นคือความลึกของ circuit
พูดให้แม่นยำ ความลึก
คือจำนวน gate สูงสุดที่พบบนเส้นทางใดๆ จากสายอินพุตไปยังสายเอาต์พุต
ซึ่งเทียบเท่ากับจำนวนชั้นของ gate ที่เราต้องใช้
เพื่อสร้าง circuit โดยชั้นหมายถึงกลุ่มของ gate
ที่สามารถทำพร้อมกันได้เพราะไม่มี
สายร่วมกัน
ตัวอย่างเช่น circuit
ของเราจากก่อนหน้านี้มีความลึกสี่ และเราเห็นจากแผนภาพได้เลยว่ามีสี่ชั้น
FANOUT gate สามารถ
ทำพร้อมกันได้ NOT gate สามารถ
ทำพร้อมกันได้ และ AND gate ก็สามารถ
ทำพร้อมกันได้เช่นกัน
ดังนั้นเราคิดว่าความลึก circuit แสดงถึงเวลาทำงานแบบขนาน
ความลึก circuit เป็นแนวคิดที่น่าสนใจและสำคัญ และมีเทคนิค
ขั้นสูงบางอย่างที่สามารถใช้ลด
ความลึกที่ต้องใช้สำหรับการคำนวณบางอย่าง บางทีก็อย่างมากเลย แต่มันเป็นหัวข้อขั้นสูง
และเราจะไม่พูดถึงมันมากนักในซีรีส์นี้
อีกครั้ง เราจะ
วัดต้นทุนการคำนวณในแง่ของขนาด
circuit หรือพูดอีกอย่างคือ
จำนวนการดำเนินการพื้นฐานที่ต้องใช้เพื่อทำการคำนวณ
ตอนต้นบทเรียน เราพูดถึงปัญหา
การแยกตัวประกอบจำนวนเต็ม และเราเห็นว่าเวลาที่อัลกอริทึมใช้แก้ปัญหานี้
สามารถเพิ่มขึ้นเมื่ออินพุตยาวขึ้น และนี่คือ
ประเด็นที่เรามักโฟกัส
เมื่อเราวิเคราะห์อัลกอริทึม
นั่นคือ เราสนใจว่าต้นทุนของการรันอัลกอริทึมเพิ่มขึ้นยังไงเมื่ออินพุตใหญ่ขึ้นเรื่อยๆ
แน่นอน การขยายขนาดแบบนี้ไม่ใช่สิ่งเดียวที่สำคัญ
ตัวอย่างเช่น เราอาจแค่สนใจหาตัวประกอบ
ของ RSA1024 แล้วจบ
ในกรณีแบบนั้น เราจะพูดถึง
อินสแตนซ์ปัญหาเดียวที่ไม่มีอะไรเพิ่มขึ้น
แต่เมื่อเราคิดเรื่องอัลกอริทึม วิธีที่ต้นทุน
ขยายขนาดสำคัญมากและบอกเราได้เยอะ
เกี่ยวกับอัลกอริทึม
มุมมองนี้
สอดคล้องกับแนวคิดที่ว่าอัลกอริทึมเป็นสิ่งพื้นฐาน และอย่างที่ผมพูดไปก่อนหน้านี้
เมื่อเวลาผ่านไปและเทคโนโลยีก้าวหน้า มันจะถูกนำไปใช้กับ
อินพุตที่ใหญ่ขึ้นเรื่อยๆ
แต่สังเกตว่าอินพุตของปัญหาการคำนวณ
สามารถมีขนาดเพิ่มขึ้นได้ แต่ circuit ไม่โต
แต่ละ circuit มีขนาดคงที่
และด้วยเหตุผลนั้น ถ้าเราต้องการอธิบาย
อัลกอริทึมโดยใช้ circuit เราจะต้องการตระกูลของ circuit
และตระกูลของ circuit หมายถึงชุดของ circuit ที่ใหญ่ขึ้นเรื่อยๆ เพื่อที่เราจะรองรับอินพุต
เมื่อมันใหญ่ขึ้นเรื่อยๆ ตัวอย่างเช่น มาดูอัลกอริทึมแบบกำหนดได้คลาสสิก
สำหรับปัญหาการแยกตัวประกอบจำนวนเต็ม อาจเป็นอันที่ใช้ trial division แต่รายละเอียดไม่สำคัญ
สำหรับตัวอย่างนี้
ในหลักการ เราสามารถ
อธิบายอัลกอริทึมแบบนั้นโดยใช้ตระกูลของ Boolean circuit ที่ถ้าเราต้องการแยกตัวประกอบเลข
ที่มีการแสดงเลขฐานสองเป็น N บิต เราก็หยิบ circuit CN จากตระกูลของเรา แล้วป้อนเลข
ที่เราต้องการแยกตัวประกอบ
เข้าไปในบิตอินพุตของ circuit นั้น
บางทีเราอาจเลือกกำหนดพารามิเตอร์ให้
circuit เหล่านี้ด้วยวิธีอื่น ดังนั้นอาจไม่ใช่ทุกครั้งที่ circuit ที่ N จะมี N บิตอินพุต
แต่เป็นวิธีที่ค่อนข้างทั่วไป โดยธรรมชาติ เมื่อ
ความยาวอินพุตยาวขึ้น เราคาดว่า circuit
ในตระกูลนี้จะใหญ่ขึ้น
สะท้อนความจริงที่ว่า
การแยกตัวประกอบเลข 4 บิตง่ายกว่าการแยกตัวประกอบเลข 1,024 บิตมาก
ดังนั้น ด้วยเหตุนี้ เราวัดต้นทุนของ
อัลกอริทึมดังกล่าวด้วยฟังก์ชัน ซึ่งบอกเราว่าต้องใช้
การดำเนินการพื้นฐานกี่ตัว
สำหรับแต่ละความยาวอินพุตที่เป็นไปได้ และเราทำแบบนี้ได้สำหรับทั้งอัลกอริทึมคลาสสิกและควอนตัม
เป็นตัวอย่าง มาดูปัญหาการบวกจำนวนเต็ม ซึ่งง่ายกว่า
การแยกตัวประกอบมาก
หรือแม้แต่การคำนวณ GCD
เพื่อให้ง่าย สมมติว่าทั้ง N และ
M เป็นจำนวนเต็มไม่เป็นลบ และแสดง
ด้วยสตริงเลขฐานสองที่มีความยาวเท่ากัน
เราจะสร้าง Boolean circuit ที่บวกเลขสองตัวนี้ได้ยังไง?
มาเริ่มกับอัลกอริทึม อัลกอริทึมมาตรฐานสำหรับการบวก ซึ่งเป็นแบบฐานสองของวิธี
ที่ผมเชื่อว่าเราทุกคนเรียนมาสำหรับบวกเลข
ด้วยดินสอและกระดาษ เราเริ่มจาก
บิตที่มีนัยสำคัญน้อยที่สุด
บวกมันเข้าด้วยกัน และนั่นให้เรา
บิตที่มีนัยสำคัญน้อยที่สุดของผลลัพธ์ พร้อมกับบิตทดที่เรา
ต้องพิจารณา
เมื่อเราเลื่อนไปตำแหน่งถัดไป และเราเลื่อนผ่านบิตไปเรื่อยๆ สร้างบิตเอาต์พุต
พร้อมกับบิตทด
จนกว่าจะถึงตอนจบ
วิธีนี้สามารถ
แสดงค่อนข้างตรงๆ ในรูปของ Boolean circuit
วิธีคิดอย่างหนึ่งคือเริ่มจาก circuit เล็กๆ สำหรับบวกจำนวนเต็มหนึ่งบิตสองตัวเข้าด้วยกัน
นั่นจะให้เราเลข
ระหว่างศูนย์ถึงสอง โดยบิตที่มีนัยสำคัญน้อยกว่าคือ XOR ของบิตอินพุต
และบิตที่มีนัยสำคัญมากกว่า หรือบิตทดก็ได้ คือ AND ของบิตอินพุตสองตัว
บางทีเราเรียก circuit ที่ทำ
สองการดำเนินการนี้พร้อมกันว่า half adder
มันใช้ได้ดีเมื่อ
มีแค่สองบิตอินพุต แต่ถ้าเราต้องการบวกจำนวนเต็มที่มีมากกว่าหนึ่งบิต
เราจะต้องจัดการ
กับบิตทดด้วยวิธีใดวิธีหนึ่ง
สิ่งที่เราทำได้คือต่อ
half adder สองตัวเข้าด้วยกันแบบต่อเนื่อง และเอา OR ของ
บิตทดที่ได้มาสร้างสิ่งที่เรียกว่า full adder
ซึ่งโดยพื้นฐานแล้วคือ Boolean circuit สำหรับบวกเลขหนึ่งบิต
สามตัวเข้าด้วยกัน
และเมื่อเรามี full adder แล้ว เราก็บวกเลขได้
โดยต่อเนื่องไป จากบิตที่มีนัยสำคัญน้อยที่สุด
ไปยังบิตที่มีนัยสำคัญมากที่สุด เราแค่สร้างอัลกอริทึมการบวกมาตรฐานโดยใช้ full adder เพื่อ
จัดการกับบิตทด
แล้วต้นทุนของการคำนวณนี้เป็นเท่าไหร่?
เราต้องใช้ gate พื้นฐาน
เจ็ดตัวสำหรับ XOR gate แต่ละตัว ซึ่งหมายถึง 10 gate สำหรับ half adder
และดังนั้น 21 gate สำหรับ full adder ซึ่งคือ half adder สองตัวบวก OR gate หนึ่งตัว
ดังนั้นสุดท้ายแล้ว ถ้าเลขอินพุตทั้งสองตัวมี N บิต เราต้องใช้ half adder สำหรับ
บิตที่มีนัยสำคัญน้อยที่สุด
และ full adder สำหรับทุกบิตอื่น และผลลัพธ์คือ 21 คูณ N ลบหนึ่ง บวก 10 หรือ 21N ลบ 11 gate ทั้งหมด
ถ้าเราตัดสินใจด้วยเหตุผลบางอย่างว่าไม่อยาก
นับ FANOUT gate และรวม XOR
gate ไว้ในชุด gate ของเรา เราต้องใช้ 5N ลบ
สาม gate ทั้งหมด
มันดีที่รู้ว่าต้องใช้กี่ gate หรือการดำเนินการพื้นฐานในการทำการคำนวณต่างๆ
อย่างที่เราเพิ่งเห็นกับการบวกจำนวนเต็ม
และแน่นอน ถ้าเราต้องการสร้างการคำนวณพวกนี้จริงๆ เราต้องรู้รายละเอียดเหล่านี้
แต่ถ้าเราลงรายละเอียดขนาดนี้ทุกครั้ง โดยเฉพาะสำหรับ
อัลกอริทึมที่ซับซ้อนกว่า เราจะจมอยู่ในรายละเอียด
ที่ในหลายกรณีมี
ความสำคัญรอง
วิธีหนึ่งที่จะทำให้เรื่องง่ายขึ้นที่พบบ่อยมากใน
การวิเคราะห์อัลกอริทึมคือการใช้ big-O notation
ซึ่งช่วยให้เรา
แสดงและเปรียบเทียบอัตราการเติบโตได้อย่างง่ายดาย
ซึ่งสะดวกมาก
และตรงนี้จะเห็นนิยามที่อยู่เบื้องหลังสัญกรณ์นี้
สมมติว่าเรามี
ฟังก์ชันสองตัว G และ H ซึ่งเราคิดว่ามีค่าเป็นจำนวนเต็ม
ไม่เป็นลบเพื่อความง่าย
แม้ว่าจริงๆ แล้วมันไม่จำเป็น อาจจะ G และ H แสดงต้นทุนของการคำนวณต่างๆ เป็นต้น
จากนั้นเราบอกว่า G เป็น big-O ของ H ซึ่งโดยทั่วไปเขียน
ด้วยเครื่องหมายเท่ากับแบบนี้
ถ้า G ของ N มีค่าไม่เกิน
ค่าคงที่บวก C คูณ H ของ N ตราบใดที่ N ใหญ่พอ
ดังนั้นนี่เป็นเรื่องของ
สิ่งที่เกิดขึ้นเมื่อ N มีค่ามาก
ในทางการ สิ่งที่ "ใหญ่พอ" หมายความว่าคือมีค่า N ศูนย์ที่เลือกได้ ที่ทำให้อสมการเป็นจริง
เมื่อใดก็ตามที่ N มีค่าอย่างน้อย N ศูนย์
กุญแจสำคัญคือ
ตัวเลข C และ N ศูนย์เหล่านี้คงที่
มันจะเป็นเลขอะไรก็ได้
แต่ไม่ว่าจะเป็นอะไร มันเปลี่ยนไม่ได้เมื่อ N โต
ถ้าคุณไม่เคยเห็น
นิยามแบบนี้มาก่อน อาจต้องใช้เวลาทำความเข้าใจ และมีทรัพยากร
ที่จะอธิบายแนวคิดนี้
ในรายละเอียดมากกว่า
ที่ผมทำได้ในบทเรียนนี้
สิ่งที่เรามักจะทำคือเลือก
ฟังก์ชัน H ให้เรียบง่ายเพื่อแสดงบางอย่างเกี่ยวกับว่าฟังก์ชัน G เติบโตเร็วแค่ไหน
ตัวอย่างเช่น ฟังก์ชันที่มีค่า 17 คูณ N กำลังสาม ลบ 257
คูณ N กำลังสอง บวก
65,537 เป็น big-O ของ N กำลังสาม และคุณสามารถใส่ตัวอย่างนี้
ในนิยาม
โดยเลือก C และ N ศูนย์ให้เหมาะสม
ตัวอย่างเช่น ถ้าเราให้ C เป็น 18 เราก็จะได้ว่า
นิพจน์นั้นมีค่าไม่เกิน 18 คูณ N กำลังสาม
ตราบใดที่ N ใหญ่พอ
เชื่อมสัญกรณ์นี้กลับไปที่
ตัวอย่างการบวกจำนวนเต็ม สิ่งที่เราพูดได้ตอนนี้คือมีตระกูลของ Boolean circuit
สำหรับบวกจำนวนเต็มไม่เป็นลบเข้าด้วยกัน ที่ขนาดของ circuit ที่ N คือตัวที่ใช้
สำหรับอินพุตความยาว N
เป็น big-O ของ N ขนาดจริงของ CN
ตามการวิเคราะห์ของเราคือ 21 คูณ N ลบ 11
แต่นั่นเป็น big-O ของ N
มันไม่ใช่เรื่องฉลาดเสมอไปที่จะทิ้งรายละเอียดแบบนี้ แต่ตรงนี้มันสมเหตุสมผล
เพราะมันเผยให้เห็นธรรมชาติที่แท้จริงของอัลกอริทึมการบวกมาตรฐาน ซึ่งก็คือต้นทุนขยายเชิงเส้น
ตามขนาดของเลข
ที่เราบวกเข้าด้วยกัน และนิพจน์นี้ไม่ไวต่อรายละเอียดระดับล่าง
ของโมเดลเรา
เช่น gate ไหนกันแน่ที่เราถือว่าเป็นการดำเนินการพื้นฐาน
ตัวอย่างเช่น ถ้าเราตัดสินใจว่า XOR gate ควรถูกถือเป็น
การดำเนินการพื้นฐาน หรือ FANOUT gate ไม่ควร
นับเป็น gate หรือทั้งสองอย่าง
เราก็ยังได้ว่าการบวกจำนวนเต็มคำนวณได้ที่ต้นทุน big-O ของ N
นี่อีกตัวอย่างของ
ปัญหาการคำนวณ การคูณจำนวนเต็ม
คล้ายกับการบวก เราสามารถถามว่าต้นทุน
ของการคำนวณนี้เป็นเท่าไหร่
ถ้าเราพิจารณาอัลกอริทึม
การคูณมาตรฐาน คือแบบฐานสองของวิธีคูณเลข
ที่สอนในโรงเรียนประถม
ซึ่งก็คือการ
เลื่อนบิตและบวกเมื่อทำงานกับเลขฐานสอง เราพบว่ามี Boolean circuit ที่มีขนาด big-O ของ N กำลังสอง
สำหรับคูณจำนวนเต็ม N บิต
ผมจะไม่ลงรายละเอียดอันนี้ แน่นอนว่า circuit
ซับซ้อนกว่าอันสำหรับการบวกเล็กน้อย แต่ถ้าคุณคิดเรื่องวิธีการ
ที่อัลกอริทึม
การคูณมาตรฐานทำงาน มันไม่น่าแปลกใจ
โดยพื้นฐาน เราต้อง
ทำการบวกประมาณ N ครั้ง แต่ละครั้งมีต้นทุนเชิงเส้น และดังนั้นเราจึงได้
ต้นทุนกำลังสองโดยรวม
สามารถทำเป็นกรณีทั่วไปได้ ถ้าเลขหนึ่งมี N บิตและอีกตัวมี M บิต เราต้องใช้ circuit
ขนาด big-O ของ N คูณ M
ตรงนี้ เราใช้ส่วนขยายของ big-O notation ที่มีตัวแปรหลายตัว แต่สามารถขยายได้แบบนี้
และถ้าสนใจ
รายละเอียดเฉพาะ ขอแนะนำให้ดู
เนื้อหาตำราเรียนของบทเรียนนี้ ซึ่งลิงก์อยู่ใน
คำอธิบายวิดีโอ
จริงๆ แล้วเป็นไปได้
ที่จะคูณจำนวนเต็ม N บิตสองตัว
ในวิธีที่ดีกว่าอัลกอริทึมการคูณมาตรฐานในเชิง asymptotic
โดยเฉพาะ อัลกอริทึมการคูณ Schonhage-Strassen
คูณจำนวนเต็ม N บิตสองตัว ที่ต้นทุน big-O ของ
N คูณความยาวของ N
คูณความยาวของความยาวของ N ดังนั้นเมื่อ N มีค่ามาก เช่น
หลายหมื่นบิต
นี่เป็นวิธี
ที่มีประสิทธิภาพมากกว่าจริงๆ แต่มันซับซ้อนและค่าใช้จ่ายเบื้องต้นทำให้ไม่เหมาะ
สำหรับเลขเล็กๆ
มาเพิ่มการคูณ
เข้าไปในรายการตัวอย่างของเรา
และเพื่อความง่าย แสดงต้นทุนที่ได้จากอัลกอริทึมการคูณมาตรฐาน ซึ่งคือ big-O ของ N กำลังสอง
อีกครั้ง เราโฟกัสที่ธรรมชาติที่แท้จริงของต้นทุนนี้ ซึ่งคือมันขยายแบบกำลังสอง
หรือต่ำกว่ากำลังสอง ถ้าเราใช้วิธีที่ดีกว่าในเชิง asymptotic
เราสามารถพิจารณา
ปัญหาการหารจำนวนเต็มด้วย ซึ่งแสดงอย่างแม่นยำบนหน้าจอ
ตรงนี้เราพูดถึงการคำนวณผลหารและเศษ ดังนั้นคำตอบประกอบด้วย
จำนวนเต็มสองตัว Q และ R
อีกครั้ง มีอัลกอริทึม
มาตรฐานสำหรับการหาร และมันก็มีต้นทุน
กำลังสองเช่นกัน และเหมือนการคูณ
ก็มีอัลกอริทึมที่ดีกว่า
ในเชิง asymptotic
แล้วอัลกอริทึม GCD เปรียบเทียบกันยังไง?
อัลกอริทึมของ Euclid
กลับกลายเป็นว่ามีต้นทุนกำลังสอง และนั่นคือสิ่งที่ผม
หมายถึงก่อนหน้านี้ในบทเรียนเมื่อผมบอกว่าเราคำนวณ GCD ได้
ที่ต้นทุนใกล้เคียงกับการคูณเลขสองตัวเข้าด้วยกัน
อีกครั้ง มีอัลกอริทึม
ที่ดีกว่าในเชิง asymptotic ในแนวทางคล้ายๆ กับ
การบวกและการคูณ
แม้ว่าต้นทุนจะ
สูงกว่าเล็กน้อยในกรณีนี้ อย่างน้อยเท่าที่เรารู้
ผมจะพูดถึงอีกตัวอย่างหนึ่งของปัญหาที่จะเพิ่มเข้ามา นั่นคือ modular exponentiation
ตรงนี้มีตัวเลขอินพุต
สามตัว K, M และ N และเป้าหมายคือคำนวณ
N ยกกำลัง K มอดุโล M
ซึ่งหมายถึงเศษ
หลังจากหารด้วย M
มันไม่ชัดเจนเลย แต่เราสามารถคำนวณ modular
exponentiation ที่ต้นทุนกำลังสาม คือ big-O ของ N กำลังสาม
สำหรับจำนวนเต็ม N บิต
วิธีทำอันนี้คือไม่ใช่คำนวณ N ยกกำลัง K ก่อนแล้วค่อยคำนวณเศษ
แค่เขียน N ยกกำลัง K ก็อาจต้องใช้บิตจำนวนมากแบบเอ็กซ์โพเนนเชียล ดังนั้นวิธีนั้นใช้ไม่ได้
แทนที่จะทำแบบนั้น เราใช้อัลกอริทึม
ที่เรียกว่า power algorithm หรือ repeated squaring ที่ทุกอย่างทำมอดุโล M
และเราใช้บิตของ
K เพื่อยกกำลังสองและคูณแบบวนซ้ำ
ในวิธีที่ทำให้มันทำงานได้
อันนี้แพงกว่า
อันอื่นๆ แต่เราก็ยังสามารถทำ
modular exponentiation ได้อย่างรวดเร็วบนเลข
ที่มีหลายพันบิต
แล้วต้นทุนของงานเหล่านี้เปรียบเทียบกับการแยกตัวประกอบจำนวนเต็มยังไง?
ถ้าเริ่มง่ายๆ และ
คิดเรื่อง trial division ที่เราเช็คก่อนว่าสองเป็นตัวประกอบของเลขอินพุตไหม
แล้วเช็คสาม และต่อไปเรื่อยๆ เราจะได้อัลกอริทึม
ที่ค่อนข้างแพง big-O ของ N กำลังสอง คูณ
สองยกกำลัง N หารสอง
การหารแต่ละครั้งใช้เวลากำลังสอง และในกรณีแย่ที่สุด เราต้องค้นหาตัวประกอบเฉพาะจนถึงรากที่สองของเลขอินพุต
และนั่นคือที่มาของ N
หารสอง ถ้าเราไม่เจอ
ตัวประกอบเฉพาะถึงจุดนั้น เราก็หยุดได้เลยเพราะ
ตัวเลขอินพุตเองต้องเป็นจำนวนเฉพาะ
นี่แพงมาก เพราะ N ปรากฏเป็นเลขชี้กำลังในนิพจน์นี้ หมายความว่า
อัลกอริทึมนี้มีต้นทุนเอ็กซ์โพเนนเชียล
ในทางตรงข้าม ตัวอย่างทั้งหมดที่อยู่ในกล่องนี้มีสิ่งที่เราเรียกว่าต้นทุนพหุนาม ที่ N ถูกยกกำลัง
แต่กำลังนั้นเป็นเลขคงที่เสมอที่ไม่โตขึ้นเมื่อ
ความยาวอินพุตโต
ในกรณีพวกนี้ กำลัง
คือหนึ่ง สอง และสาม
ผมจะกลับมาเรื่องต้นทุนพหุนามกับเอ็กซ์โพเนนเชียลอีกสักครู่ แต่ก่อนอื่น มา
จัดการเรื่องการแยกตัวประกอบให้เสร็จ
ก่อนหน้านี้ผมพูดถึง
number field sieve ซึ่งเป็นอัลกอริทึม
แยกตัวประกอบที่ดีที่สุดที่เรามี ในแง่ของวิธีที่ต้นทุนขยาย
จริงๆ แล้ว ต้นทุนของอัลกอริทึมนี้ยังไม่ได้ถูกพิสูจน์อย่างเข้มงวด เพราะมันเชื่อมโยงกับคำถามเปิดเกี่ยวกับทฤษฎีจำนวน
แต่มีการคาดว่าจะมี
ต้นทุนที่ดูเหมือนแบบนี้
คราวนี้ big-O อยู่ในเลขชี้กำลัง แต่ผมจะ
เก็บรายละเอียดนั้นไว้ก่อน
สิ่งสำคัญที่ต้องจำคือมันดีกว่า
trial division อย่างมาก เพราะถึงแม้ N จะ
อยู่ในเลขชี้กำลัง
มันถูกยกกำลัง 1/3 และนั่นแปลว่าต้นทุนต่ำกว่ามาก และนั่นคือเหตุผลที่อัลกอริทึมนี้
จัดการเลขอย่าง RSA250 ได้ ในขณะที่ trial division
ทำไม่ได้แน่นอน
แต่มันก็ยังเป็นเอ็กซ์โพเนนเชียลอยู่ ในแง่ที่ว่ากำลังของ N ปรากฏในเลขชี้กำลัง และดังนั้น
มันยังจัดการ
เลขอย่าง RSA1024 ไม่ได้
ตอนนี้ผมจะพูดเพิ่มเติมเรื่องต้นทุนพหุนาม
กับต้นทุนเอ็กซ์โพเนนเชียล
เราบอกว่าอัลกอริทึม
มีต้นทุนพหุนาม ถ้าต้นทุนเป็น big-O ของ N ยกกำลัง B
ที่ B เป็นจำนวนบวกใดๆ แต่กุญแจสำคัญคือ B ต้องคงที่ หมายความว่ามันไม่เปลี่ยน
เมื่อความยาวอินพุต N โต
สำหรับตัวอย่างที่เราเห็นเมื่อกี้ คือการบวก คูณ หาร คำนวณ GCD
และ modular exponentiation
เราได้ว่า B เป็น
หนึ่ง สอง หรือสาม
ดังนั้นพวกนี้เป็น
อัลกอริทึมที่มีต้นทุนพหุนามทั้งหมด
แต่เมื่อเราพูดว่าต้นทุน
พหุนามโดยทั่วไป B จะเป็นจำนวนบวกใดๆ ก็ได้
อาจจะเป็นหนึ่งล้านก็ได้
แต่มันต้องคงที่
โดยการประมาณคร่าวๆ อัลกอริทึมที่มีต้นทุน
พหุนามมักถูกมองว่าเป็นตัวแทนของอัลกอริทึมที่มีประสิทธิภาพ
มันเป็นการทำให้ง่ายเกินไปแน่นอน แต่เป็นแนวทางคร่าวๆ คุณสามารถคิดว่า
อัลกอริทึมต้นทุนพหุนาม
ใช้ประโยชน์จาก
โครงสร้างของปัญหาเพื่อสร้างคำตอบ ตรงข้ามกับวิธี
แบบ brute force
หรือการค้นหาแบบครอบคลุม
ทั่วพื้นที่ขนาดใหญ่มาก
แน่นอน อัลกอริทึมที่ต้นทุนขยายเป็น N ยกกำลังหนึ่งล้าน
บนอินพุตความยาว N
จะไม่ถูก
มองว่ามีประสิทธิภาพอย่างสมเหตุสมผล และเราไม่คาดว่าจะ
รันมันบนอินพุตขนาดใหญ่ได้
แต่ถึงอย่างนั้น อัลกอริทึม N ยกกำลัง
หนึ่งล้านต้องทำอะไรบางอย่างที่ฉลาดที่สะท้อนโครงสร้าง
ของปัญหาที่มันแก้ เพื่อหลีกเลี่ยงการขยายต้นทุนแบบเอ็กซ์โพเนนเชียลที่จะเกี่ยวข้องกับ
การค้นหาแบบครอบคลุมทั่วพื้นที่ขนาดใหญ่
และในทางปฏิบัติ การค้นพบอัลกอริทึมที่มีต้นทุนพหุนามเป็นแค่
ก้าวแรกสู่ประสิทธิภาพ
ถ้าปัญหาหนึ่งสำคัญ
และมีคนค้นพบอัลกอริทึมต้นทุนพหุนาม
ตัวแรกสำหรับมัน อาจมีเลขชี้กำลังที่สูงมาก
คุณมั่นใจได้อย่างสมเหตุสมผลว่านักออกแบบอัลกอริทึม
จะหาการปรับปรุงที่ทำให้เลขชี้กำลังนั้นลดลง
โดยสาระสำคัญ คุณสามารถ
มองว่าการมีอยู่ของอัลกอริทึมต้นทุน
พหุนามสำหรับปัญหาหนึ่งเป็นการแสดงให้เห็นความเป็นไปได้
ในการแก้ปัญหานั้น
บนอินพุตที่มีขนาดพอสมควร แต่อาจยังมีงานอีกมากที่ต้องทำเพื่อไปถึงประสิทธิภาพที่แท้จริง
ในทฤษฎีความซับซ้อน มักจะบอกว่าต้นทุนของอัลกอริทึม
ขยายแบบ sub-exponential ถ้าต้นทุนเป็น big-O ของสองยกกำลัง N
ยกกำลัง epsilon สำหรับทุกจำนวนจริงบวก epsilon และถ้ามันไม่ใช่ sub-exponential
มันก็เป็นเอ็กซ์โพเนนเชียล หรืออาจเป็น super-exponential เช่น สองยกกำลังสองยกกำลัง N
ซึ่งเป็น doubly exponential
แต่ตราบใดที่เอาต์พุต
ไม่ยาวแบบ super-exponential ทุกปัญหาจริงๆ สามารถถูก
คำนวณด้วย Boolean circuit
ที่มีต้นทุนเอ็กซ์โพเนนเชียล ดังนั้นความแตกต่างที่สำคัญตรงนี้คือระหว่างต้นทุนพหุนาม
กับเอ็กซ์โพเนนเชียล
เราไม่รู้จักอัลกอริทึมคลาสสิกที่มีต้นทุน sub-exponential สำหรับ
การแยกตัวประกอบจำนวนเต็ม
ตัวอย่างเช่น ต้นทุนของ number field sieve ไม่ใช่ big-O ของสองยกกำลัง
N ยกกำลัง epsilon เมื่อ epsilon เป็น 1/3 หรือน้อยกว่า
ดังนั้นมันไม่เข้านิยามนี้
มันเป็นอัลกอริทึมที่ฉลาดมากอย่างไม่ต้องสงสัย แต่มันก็ยังเป็น sieve และเรายังคงค้นหา
ทั่วพื้นที่ขนาดใหญ่มากเพื่อระบุตัวประกอบของเลขที่กำหนดให้
อย่างที่เราจะเห็นในบทเรียนถัดไป จริงๆ แล้วมีอัลกอริทึมควอนตัม
ที่มีต้นทุนพหุนามสำหรับการแยกตัวประกอบจำนวนเต็ม
อัลกอริทึมของ Shor มีต้นทุนพหุนาม และโดยเฉพาะมีต้นทุนกำลังสาม คล้ายกับ modular exponentiation
ปัญหาอีกกลุ่มหนึ่งที่
คุณอาจคุ้นเคยคือกลุ่มปัญหา NP-complete
ผมจะไม่ลงรายละเอียดว่าปัญหา NP-complete คืออะไรในบทเรียนนี้ แต่ลองค้นหา
ดูได้ถ้าสนใจ
มีการคาดว่า
ไม่มีปัญหาพวกนี้มีต้นทุน sub-exponential
นั่นเป็นเวอร์ชันที่ใช้ circuit ของสิ่งที่บางทีเรียกว่า
exponential time hypothesis แต่จนถึงตอนนี้ยังไม่มีใคร
สามารถหาวิธีพิสูจน์มันได้
จริงๆ แล้ว เราไม่สามารถพิสูจน์ได้ด้วยซ้ำว่าไม่มีอัลกอริทึมต้นทุนเชิงเส้นสำหรับปัญหา NP-complete
มันยากมากจริงๆ
อย่างน้อยเท่าที่เรารู้ ที่จะตัด
ความเป็นไปได้ของการค้นพบอัลกอริทึม
ที่สร้างสรรค์อย่างเหลือเชื่อสำหรับปัญหาเหล่านี้ในอนาคต
นี่คือรูปที่
แสดงความสัมพันธ์ระหว่างต้นทุนพหุนามและเอ็กซ์โพเนนเชียล
บนแกน X เรามีความยาวอินพุตของปัญหาที่เรากำลังคิดอยู่ และแกน Y แสดง
ต้นทุนของการแก้ปัญหานั้น
หรือคุณจะคิดว่า
เป็นเวลาที่ต้องใช้แก้ปัญหาก็ได้
อัลกอริทึมต้นทุนเอ็กซ์โพเนนเชียล
อาจขยายแบบนี้
สำหรับอินพุตสั้นๆ ต้นทุนอาจไม่สูงเป็นพิเศษ เช่น แยก
ตัวประกอบเลข 12 เป็นต้น
แต่เมื่อความยาวอินพุตยาวขึ้น ต้นทุนจะพุ่งสูงขึ้นในที่สุด
อัลกอริทึมต้นทุนพหุนาม
ในทางกลับกัน อาจมีการขยายแบบนี้
ต้นทุนจะยังเพิ่มขึ้นโดยทั่วไปเมื่ออินพุตยาวขึ้น และอาจแพงกว่าอัลกอริทึมต้นทุน
เอ็กซ์โพเนนเชียลสำหรับบางอินพุตด้วยซ้ำ
แต่ในที่สุดมันจะ
ถูกกว่าอัลกอริทึมต้นทุนเอ็กซ์โพเนนเชียลมาก และมันไม่พุ่ง
ในแบบสุดขั้วเดียวกัน
ที่อัลกอริทึมต้นทุนเอ็กซ์โพเนนเชียลทำ
ถ้าเราจินตนาการว่า
เรามีต้นทุนสูงสุดที่เรายอมจ่าย หรือเวลาสูงสุดที่เรายอมรอคำตอบ
ถ้าชอบคิดเป็นเวลา อัลกอริทึมต้นทุนเอ็กซ์โพเนนเชียลจะใช้ได้แค่กับอินพุต
จนถึงความยาวที่กำหนด
ในขณะที่โดยทั่วไป
อัลกอริทึมต้นทุนพหุนามจะให้เราแก้
ปัญหาสำหรับอินพุตที่ใหญ่กว่าได้
และนั่นคือเหตุผลที่ เราสามารถคำนวณ GCD สำหรับเลขที่มีหลายพัน
บิตได้อย่างง่ายดาย แต่ในกรณีแย่ที่สุด
เราแยกตัวประกอบเลขขนาดนี้ไม่ได้
ในส่วนสุดท้ายของบทเรียน เราจะหันมาสนใจเรื่องการสร้างการคำนวณคลาสสิก
บนคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัม
พูดให้เฉพาะเจาะจงกว่า เราจะ
เห็นว่าการคำนวณใดๆ ที่ทำได้ด้วย Boolean circuit ก็ทำได้ด้วย quantum circuit เช่นกัน
ที่ต้นทุนใกล้เคียงกัน ยิ่งกว่านั้น สามารถ
ทำได้อย่างสะอาดซึ่งสำคัญถ้าเรา
ต้องการรันการคำนวณเหล่านี้
เป็นซับรูทีนภายใน
การคำนวณควอนตัมที่ใหญ่กว่า และผมจะอธิบายว่า "สะอาด" หมายถึงอะไรเมื่อเราเข้าไปลึกกว่านี้
เราจะใช้
Toffoli gate ในกระบวนการนี้
จำได้ว่า Toffoli gate คือ controlled-controlled-NOT gate ดังนั้นการกระทำต่อ standard basis state
เป็นอย่างที่เห็นบนหน้าจอ
สังเกตว่าเราสามารถ
มอง Toffoli gate เหมือนเป็น query gate
สำหรับฟังก์ชัน AND
ไม่ได้หมายความว่ามันเป็น query gate ในความหมายตรงตัว อย่างที่ผมพูดตอนต้นบทเรียน เราไม่ได้ทำงานภายใน
โมเดล query ตอนนี้
แต่การกระทำของมันเป็นไปตามรูปแบบเดียวกับ query gate
เราสามารถคิดว่าค่าไบนารี A และ B เป็นอินพุตของฟังก์ชัน AND และเหมือน query gate
ค่าเหล่านี้ถูก
สะท้อนกลับเป็นส่วนหนึ่งของเอาต์พุต และค่าของฟังก์ชัน คือ AND เชิงตรรกะของ A และ B
ถูก XOR ลงบน qubit ล่าง ทีนี้ เราไม่ได้รวม Toffoli gate ในชุด gate มาตรฐานของเรา
เราเปลี่ยนใจได้ถ้าอยาก แต่จริงๆ ไม่จำเป็น
ต้องทำแบบนั้น เพราะอีกทางหนึ่ง เราสร้าง Toffoli
gate ได้โดยใช้ Hadamard gate
T และ T dagger gate
และ controlled NOT gate อย่างที่เห็นตรงนี้
มันไม่ชัดเจนเลย
ว่า circuit นี้สร้าง Toffoli gate แต่มันทำได้ และคุณจะเชื่อผมหรือ
คูณทุกอย่างเองเพื่อฝึกเพิ่ม หรือจะถาม Qiskit หรือ Python
หรือซอฟต์แวร์ใดๆ ที่คูณเมทริกซ์ให้ทำการคูณแทนก็ได้
และลองดู
เนื้อหาตำราเรียนของบทเรียนนี้ที่ทำโดยใช้ Qiskit
ตอนนี้เราไปต่อเรื่องการจำลอง Boolean gate ด้วย quantum circuit และทั้งหมดที่ต้องใช้
คือ NOT gate
controlled NOT gate และ Toffoli gate
การดำเนินการเหล่านี้เป็นแบบกำหนดได้ นอกเหนือจากการเป็นยูนิทารี และบางทีเราอธิบาย
การดำเนินการแบบนี้ว่าเป็นแบบย้อนกลับได้ และจริงๆ แล้ว
การศึกษาการคำนวณแบบย้อนกลับได้มีมาก่อนการคำนวณควอนตัม และนั่นคือที่มาของ
กระบวนการทั้งหมดนี้
Boolean gate ที่เราต้อง
จัดการคือ NOT gate, AND gate และ FANOUT gate
และสิ่งที่เราจะแสดงคือเราสามารถสร้าง gate เหล่านี้ หรือจำลองมัน
โดยใช้ NOT gate
controlled NOT gate และ Toffoli gate
พูดให้ชัด สิ่งที่เรา
ต้องการคือ quantum circuit ที่ให้เราคำนวณค่าของ Boolean gate ที่ผมเพิ่งพูดถึง
เมื่อเราให้ qubit ใน
standard basis state เป็นอินพุต
สำหรับอินพุตที่เป็นควอนตัมสเตทใดๆ การกระทำจะถูกกำหนด
โดยความเชิงเส้นตามปกติ
เราไม่ต้องทำอะไร
พิเศษกับ NOT gate NOT gate ก็คือ NOT gate และสร้างได้โดยตรง
และ OR gate สามารถจำลอง
ได้โดยใช้ Toffoli และ NOT gate
AND gate ง่าย โดยเฉพาะในแง่ของสิ่งที่ผมเพิ่งพูดเมื่อกี้เกี่ยวกับ Toffoli gate ที่เป็นหลักๆ
query gate ที่สร้างขึ้น
ของฟังก์ชัน AND
พูดให้แม่นยำ สิ่งที่เราทำได้คือเพิ่ม qubit ใหม่ที่ตั้งค่าเริ่มต้นเป็นสถานะศูนย์
และให้ qubit นั้นเป็น
เป้าหมายของ Toffoli gate และให้ qubit
อินพุตสองตัวเป็นตัวควบคุม
qubit พิเศษแบบนี้
มีชื่อเรียกหลายอย่าง ซึ่งมักถูกเพิ่ม
เข้ามาในการคำนวณควอนตัม และผมจะเรียกมันว่า workspace
qubit เพื่อเลือกชื่อสักอัน
สมมติฐานทั่วไปของเราเกี่ยวกับ workspace qubit คือมันเริ่มในสถานะศูนย์ และเรามักจะคืนมัน
กลับไปสถานะศูนย์ได้
เมื่อใช้เสร็จ แต่ไม่ใช่ทุกครั้ง
ในแผนภาพ เรามี ket ศูนย์อยู่ในสี่เหลี่ยมจุดเพื่อบ่งบอกว่าการตั้งค่าเริ่มต้น
ของ qubit นี้
เป็นส่วนหนึ่งของกระบวนการ และถ้าคุณไม่มี
qubit ใหม่แบบนี้ คุณจะไม่สามารถ
ทำการจำลองนี้ได้
qubit เอาต์พุตล่าง
คืออันที่เราสนใจ เพราะมันคือผลลัพธ์
ของการดำเนินการ AND และเราทำเสร็จ
แล้วกับอีกสองตัว
มันก็อยู่ในกล่องได้
จริงๆ คุณอาจจินตนาการว่าการกำจัด qubit สองตัวนี้เป็นส่วนหนึ่งของงาน
จำลอง AND gate นี้
เหมือนขยะที่
ต้องเก็บทำความสะอาด
ยังไงก็ตาม นั่นคือวิธี
จำลอง AND gate
ตอนนี้เรารู้วิธีทำ AND gate แล้ว เราก็ทำ OR gate ได้โดยใช้
กฎของ De Morgan
ถ้าใส่ NOT gate บนอินพุตสองตัวและเอาต์พุตของ AND
gate คุณจะได้ OR gate ง่ายแค่นั้น
และอันสุดท้ายคือ FANOUT สำหรับอันนี้ เราแค่
ต้องใช้ controlled NOT gate กับ workspace qubit
โดยเฉพาะ ถ้าเรา
ตั้ง workspace qubit เป็นเป้าหมาย เราก็แค่คัดลอก standard basis state ที่เข้ามา
มันก็ทำหน้าที่เป็น FANOUT gate
เรามี gate ครบทุกตัวแล้ว
และตอนนี้เรามี gate ครบหมดแล้ว เราก็ไปต่อเรื่อง circuit ได้
สมมติว่าเรามี
Boolean circuit อันหนึ่งชื่อ C และมันจะเป็น
Boolean circuit อะไรก็ได้ตามที่คุณเลือก
ตราบใดที่มันประกอบจาก
AND, OR, NOT และ FANOUT gate
ให้ T เป็นจำนวน gate ใน C และเราตั้งชื่อ F ให้กับฟังก์ชันที่ C คำนวณ
เราคิดว่า F มีรูปแบบที่เห็นตรงนี้ โดย N คือจำนวนบิตอินพุตของ C
M คือจำนวนบิตเอาต์พุต และ sigma คือตัวอักษรไบนารี
และสิ่งที่เราทำคือไล่ gate ของ C ทีละตัว
เราปล่อย NOT gate ไว้เหมือนเดิม และแทนที่ตัวอื่นด้วยการจำลอง
ที่ผมเพิ่งอธิบาย
ถ้า C ดูเหมือนนี้ สิ่งที่เราได้คือ circuit
R ที่ดูเหมือนนี้
ในแผนภาพนี้
workspace qubit ทั้งหมดที่เราต้องใช้สำหรับการจำลองถูกดึงออกจากกล่องและรวมไว้ที่ด้านล่าง
K คือจำนวนทั้งหมดของ
workspace qubit ที่เราต้องใช้ ซึ่งคือหนึ่งตัวสำหรับแต่ละ gate ของ C ยกเว้น NOT gate
สำหรับเอาต์พุตของ R เรามี qubit ที่
สอดคล้องกับเอาต์พุตของ C และตรงนี้ qubit เหล่านั้น
แสดงอยู่ด้านบน
แม้ว่ามันจะไม่สำคัญจริงๆ ตอนจบของทั้งหมดนี้
ว่ามันอยู่ด้านบนหรือไม่
พูดให้แม่นยำ สมมติว่าเราได้รัน R บน standard basis state ที่สอดคล้องกับ
สตริง N บิตใดๆ X
qubit เอาต์พุต M ตัวเหล่านี้จะอยู่ใน standard basis state
ที่สอดคล้องกับ F ของ X
เรายังมี qubit ที่เหลือทั้งหมดจาก AND และ OR gate
เรายังต้องจัดการกับมัน และถ้าเรารวมมันไว้ด้วยกัน มันจะอยู่ใน standard basis state บางอัน
standard basis state นั้นจะต้องเป็นฟังก์ชันบางอย่างของสตริง X และเราจะ
ตั้งชื่อฟังก์ชันนั้นว่า G
G เป็นฟังก์ชันใหม่ที่
ถูกกำหนดโดย gate ของ C ที่บอกเราว่า
qubit ที่เหลือเหล่านี้อยู่ในสถานะอะไร
หลังจากรัน R แล้ว G เป็นตัวอักษรถัดไปหลัง F นั่นคือเหตุผลหนึ่งที่
เรียกฟังก์ชันนี้ว่า G
แต่อีกเหตุผลที่เรียกว่า G ก็เพราะ G ย่อมาจาก garbage
พวกนี้เป็น garbage qubit ทั้งหมด และโดยเฉพาะ เรา
มี garbage qubit สองตัวสำหรับแต่ละ AND gate และ OR gate
จำนวน gate ทั้งหมด
ที่เราต้องใช้คือ big-O ของ T
เพราะสำหรับแต่ละ gate ของ C เราต้องใช้ quantum gate จำนวนจำกัด
OR gate แพงที่สุด สำหรับอันนั้น เราต้องใช้ NOT gate สามตัวกับ Toffoli gate หนึ่งตัว
และ Toffoli gate ใช้ 15 gate จากชุด gate มาตรฐานของเรา
นั่นคืออย่างมาก 18 gate
ใน R สำหรับแต่ละ gate ของ C
ถ้าอยากปรับแต่งให้ดีขึ้น ก็ทำได้ แต่สำหรับ
การวิเคราะห์ asymptotic คร่าวๆ เราแค่พูดว่า
R มี big-O ของ T gate
เราจึงคำนวณ
ฟังก์ชัน F เดียวกันกับที่ Boolean
circuit C เดิมคำนวณได้
และเราทำมันที่ต้นทุนเชิงเส้นตามขนาดของ C
ถ้าสิ่งที่เราสนใจคือ
แค่คำนวณฟังก์ชัน F นี้ เราก็เสร็จแล้ว
แต่น่าเสียดาย เรา
มี garbage qubit เหล่านี้ และ garbage qubit เหล่านี้
โดยทั่วไปจะทำลาย
รูปแบบการแทรกสอดที่ทำให้อัลกอริทึมควอนตัมทำงานได้ ถ้าเราพยายามใช้
circuit R นี้เป็นซับรูทีน
ภายในอัลกอริทึมควอนตัมที่ใหญ่กว่า
แต่เราสามารถกำจัด
garbage นี้ได้จริงๆ และวิธีทำคือใช้ประโยชน์จากข้อเท็จจริงที่ว่า circuit R สามารถกลับด้านได้
หรือพูดอีกอย่างคือ เรา
สามารถรันมันย้อนกลับได้
เพื่ออธิบายวิธีทำ สมมติว่าเรารัน R ก่อน แล้วรัน R ย้อนกลับ
ซึ่งเราแสดงเป็น R dagger
พูดให้ชัด สิ่งที่มันหมายคือเราใช้ gate
ของ R ในลำดับกลับกัน และเราเอาอินเวิร์ส
ของแต่ละ gate
NOT gate, controlled NOT
gate และ Toffoli gate เป็นอินเวิร์สของตัวเองจริงๆ ดังนั้นถ้าเราคิดในแง่
ของ gate เหล่านี้
R dagger ก็แค่ R ที่ gate เรียงในลำดับกลับกัน
แต่โดยทั่วไป เราสามารถรัน quantum circuit ยูนิทารีใดๆ ย้อนกลับได้ในวิธีที่ผมเพิ่งอธิบาย
หมายความว่าเราใช้
gate ในลำดับกลับกัน และเราแทนที่แต่ละ
gate ด้วยอินเวิร์สของมัน
ถ้าเราทำแบบนี้ เราจะพบว่ารัน R ก่อนแล้วรัน R
ย้อนกลับจะไม่ทำอะไรเลย
ถ้าเราเริ่มใน standard basis state อย่างที่เรามีตรงนี้ เราก็จะจบใน standard basis state เดิมเป๊ะ
แน่นอน แค่ทำ
แบบนั้นไม่ได้ช่วยอะไร แต่สิ่งที่เราทำได้คือเพิ่ม qubit พิเศษเข้ามาอีกกลุ่ม โดยเฉพาะ
คือ M qubit ที่ M คือจำนวนบิตเอาต์พุตของ circuit C
qubit เพิ่มเติมเหล่านี้อาจ
อยู่ในควอนตัมสเตทใดๆ แต่เพื่ออธิบายวิธีทำ เราจะสมมติว่ามันอยู่ใน standard basis state
ที่สอดคล้องกับสตริง Y บางอัน ดังนั้น Y เป็นสตริง M บิต และสิ่งที่เราทำได้คือ
controlled NOT
gate หลายตัวอย่างที่เห็นตรงนี้ ซึ่งเอา XOR ของสตริง F ของ X
ลงบนสตริง Y ที่เก็บ
ใน M qubit ล่างเหล่านี้
และเอาต์พุตของ
การคำนวณทั้งหมดก็เป็นอย่างที่ปรากฏบนหน้าจอ
X และ Y เป็นสตริงไบนารีใดๆ X มี N บิตและ Y มี M บิต และเรายังต้องใช้ K workspace qubit
เมื่อเรารัน R เราคำนวณ F ของ X และสตริงนั้นถูกเก็บ
ใน M qubit บน แต่เรายังมี
garbage qubit อีกกลุ่ม
ดังนั้นเราเอา XOR ของเอาต์พุต F ของ
X ลงบน M qubit ล่าง แล้วรัน R ย้อนกลับ
เพื่อเก็บกวาด garbage
ผมควรชี้ให้เห็นว่าสิ่งสำคัญคือ R เป็นแบบกำหนดได้
ถ้า M qubit บนเหล่านี้อยู่ในซูเปอร์โพซิชันของ
standard basis state แทน มันจะทำงานไม่ถูกต้อง
แต่มันทำงานได้เมื่อ
R เป็นแบบกำหนดได้
ถ้าเราเปรียบเทียบ quantum
circuit ที่เราเพิ่งสร้างกับ Boolean circuit C เดิม เราจะเห็นว่ามันทำงาน
ในลักษณะเดียวกัน
กับที่ query gate ทำงาน
สำหรับฟังก์ชันใดๆ
มีความแตกต่างตรงนี้ คือเราต้อง
ใช้ workspace qubit เหล่านี้เพื่อให้มันทำงานได้ แต่นอกเหนือจากนั้น เราก็
สร้าง query gate ได้จริงๆ
หรือ query circuit สำหรับฟังก์ชันใดๆ ก็ตามที่ C คำนวณ
เรายังสามารถคืน workspace
qubit กลับไปสถานะเริ่มต้นได้ด้วย ดังนั้นในหลักการมันสามารถถูกนำกลับมาใช้ใหม่
เป็น workspace qubit สำหรับ
การคำนวณถัดไป
ถ้าเราต้องการ เราสามารถใส่กรอบรอบ quantum circuit ทั้งหมดแล้วเรียกมันว่า Q และความสัมพันธ์กับ
C ก็ชัดเจนขึ้น
circuit Q จะ
ใหญ่กว่า C โดยทั่วไป เราต้องใช้ quantum
gate จำนวนหนึ่งใน Q สำหรับแต่ละ gate ของ C
และเรายังต้องใช้ controlled
NOT gate ตรงกลาง แต่จำนวนก็ยังเป็น
เชิงเส้นตามขนาดของ C
ควรสังเกตด้วยว่านี่เป็นกระบวนการที่ใช้ได้ทั่วไปอย่างสมบูรณ์ ใช้ได้กับ Boolean circuit ใดๆ และเราไม่ได้พยายามปรับแต่ง Q เลย
สำหรับ circuit C เฉพาะ อาจมี
วิธีลดขนาดของ Q และรวมถึงวิธี
ที่ลดจำนวน
workspace qubit ที่ต้องใช้ ในกรณีที่เราอยากทำ
แบบนั้น และนั่นคือกระบวนการสำหรับรัน
การคำนวณคลาสสิก
บนคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัม
มันค่อนข้างง่าย แต่มันเป็นสิ่งสำคัญ
ที่ต้องทำได้
โดยเฉพาะ ตอนนี้
เรารู้วิธีทำแล้ว เราสามารถใช้การคำนวณคลาสสิกอะไรก็ได้ที่ต้องการ
ภายในการคำนวณควอนตัม ตราบใดที่เราทำตามรูปแบบนี้ที่อินพุตถูกสะท้อนกลับ และเอาต์พุตถูก XOR
ลงบนกลุ่ม qubit
เหมือนกับที่เรามีสำหรับ query gate
ต้นทุนขยายเชิงเส้น ตัวอย่างเช่น เราสามารถ
สร้าง quantum circuit สำหรับปัญหาอย่างการบวกจำนวนเต็ม
การคูณ การหาร การคำนวณ GCD และ modular exponentiation และทั้งหมดนี้ทำได้ที่ต้นทุน asymptotic เดียวกัน
กับ Boolean circuit
เราต้องใช้ workspace qubit ทำแบบนี้ แต่อย่างน้อยมันก็พร้อมใช้ใหม่ได้เมื่อ
เราใช้เสร็จ
ข้อสังเกตสุดท้ายที่ควรพูดถึงคือวิธีนี้ให้เราวิธีสร้าง query gate
ซึ่งผมพูดถึงไว้ในบทเรียนที่แล้ว
นั่นคือ ถ้าเรามี query algorithm ที่รับฟังก์ชัน F เป็นอินพุต และเรามีวิธีคำนวณ
F ด้วย Boolean circuit
เราก็สามารถทำตามกระบวนการนี้เพื่อสร้าง query gate สำหรับฟังก์ชันนั้น แล้วรัน query algorithm บนมัน
มันจะเป็นสิ่งที่มีประโยชน์หรือไม่ขึ้นอยู่กับปัญหา query เองและสิ่งที่เราพยายามทำ แต่โดยสาระสำคัญ
โครงสร้างนี้ให้เรา
วิธีเชื่อมโมเดล query กับโมเดลการคำนวณที่เป็นมาตรฐานมากกว่า
ในแง่หนึ่ง นี่คือวิธีที่อัลกอริทึมของ Shor สำหรับการแยกตัวประกอบจำนวนเต็มทำงาน
เราจะสร้าง
quantum circuit แบบนี้จากการดำเนินการเลขคณิตบางอย่างที่เราพูดถึงก่อนหน้าในบทเรียน
และโดยการทำแบบนั้น เรา
ให้ quantum circuit ความสามารถในการประเมินการดำเนินการเหล่านั้นบนซูเปอร์โพซิชันของสถานะคลาสสิก
และอย่างที่เราจะเห็น มันทำให้เราแยกตัวประกอบจำนวนเต็มได้อย่างมีประสิทธิภาพ
นั่นคือจุดจบของบทเรียนนี้ ซึ่งโฟกัสหลักๆ ที่การสร้างพื้นฐาน
สำหรับอัลกอริทึมควอนตัมในกรอบการคำนวณ
มาตรฐานที่ไม่ใช่กล่องดำ
เราพูดถึงต้นทุนการคำนวณผ่านมุมมองของปัญหาที่เชื่อมโยงกับทฤษฎีจำนวนพื้นฐาน
เราพูดถึงต้นทุนพหุนาม
กับเอ็กซ์โพเนนเชียลสำหรับงานคำนวณ และเราเห็นว่าการคำนวณคลาสสิก
สามารถถูกสร้างด้วย quantum circuit ในลักษณะที่สะอาดปราศจาก garbage ซึ่งทำให้ใช้เป็นซับรูทีนได้
ภายในการคำนวณควอนตัมที่ใหญ่กว่า
หวังว่าคุณจะมาร่วมกันในบทเรียนถัดไป ที่เราจะเห็นว่าอัลกอริทึมของ Shor นำแนวคิดเหล่านี้ไปใช้ยังไง ทำให้เราแยกตัวประกอบ
จำนวนเต็มที่ต้นทุนพหุนาม
ลาก่อนจนกว่าจะเจอกันใหม่